the Democratic Republic of Congo has
been riven by conflict and political
instability for decades money and raw
materials are what hold influence here
entire regions are controlled by rebels
aid agencies face constant challenges
their workers are often in danger
attacks on humanitarian convoys are
commonplace in remote villages like this
one four years ago this aid worker was
stationed in a village when his team
came under rebel attack a Muni spy was
insane in June of 2010 the rebels
attacked a Maltese funded health center
at the same time a team working there
was abducted by the rebels it was a
tough situation we had to give aid and
also secure the team's release he flies
under resides the steam beside the
hospital destroyed medical help hardly
possible his team kidnapped room ish had
to negotiate yoga ban hamma composition
he's faking the rebels realized it was
about a the team was needed our main
argument was if you don't want your
people to suffer even more
you have to release our workers he's
complex when target can fremitus - 13
along with the Democratic Republic of
Congo Sudan Syria Afghanistan and
Pakistan also ranked among the most
dangerous countries for aid
organizations attacks on aid workers
have could group 'old in the past ten
years
Maltese aid workers have long been seen
as neutral but that often has not
protected them or made their work easier
it's one named intensity and the
increasing intensity and radicalization
of the armed conflict is making it more
and more difficult for us to give
humanitarian aid when and where it's
needed
with no end to the conflicts in sight
aid agencies are struggling to find a
solution to the crisis